he plays the patriarch of the Pritchett
family on Modern Family which is still
in season 10 entering coming up next
month one of the funniest shows in the
history of TV 9:00 p.m. Eastern every
single Wednesday starting September 26th
good to see you Ed O'Neill back here
thank you rich on the show to see you
now you were telling a story as we were
going to break about you were having
lunch with David this was again
I always loved you coming on here we
talk sports we talk life and I never
know what he's going on in here
incredible existence behavin David I've
known David Mamet pretty good Mamet
Pulitzer prize-winning playwright says
I've known David since 1980 yeah I
consider him one of my best friends and
he told me this story then hid when they
were doing the untouchables he wrote the
screenplay and he was directing a play
in Seattle called House of games yes
low-budget and Brian De Palma calls him
it directs directing Untouchables with
Sean Connery De Niro you know and he
says Dave you know Bobby's having some
trouble with this one scene at the
courthouse steps but we compares ties to
people and and Dave says this not my
problem
you know I sold the screenplay I'm busy
here so DePalma says well we thought
maybe you'd give it a look maybe give it
a little rewrite he says I don't have
time he said well you know we thought
maybe do us this favor he says Brian you
know what a favor is I pick your kid up
from school write favor write I rewrite
it it's 100 grand right it was Al Capone
at the steps of City Hall talking about
ties okay I don't wear it I wear a
different tie every day why so Mamet
wrote the scene with him at the baseball
bat you know he wrote the show but they
wanted him a so maybe you should get a
less famous writer to finish that scene
any day said no we want you we want your
voice as a I like the scene
to be honest with you and that's the way
it was that's the best scene in the
movie oh my word anyway Ed O'Neill here
on the Rich Eisen show now you just met
Shawne Merriman back there correct yes
right and you are as a a boxing and MMA
shinato what do you think of Shawne
Merriman 'he's idea of going well
Michael if I talked to Sean about it I
don't know you know he looks like a very
impressive guy right I mean I certainly
wouldn't want to you know right
but boxing is a lot different than
football right you know I mean the part
you have to know how to punch first of
all you exactly have to know how to
avoid punches yes exactly and it's
timing and since a distance and you know
and there's leverage you know the hips
come into play and the whole you know
there's a lot to it right Jack Dempsey
you know was 190 and would you know kill
guys right so you you know it's not just
size and well we've seen football
players attempt this before right
you know which one's too tall Jones
remember to tell Jones would box a
little bit I think he kept his chin sore
lay almost like a golf ball on the tee
yeah right you couldn't because you
can't miss it
exactly I listen I wish him the best of
luck but right you know you're doing one
contact sport I don't know why you
dabble in the other right so it
described for me a night where you're
watching a fight in the ED O'Neill
household what do you got I usually
watch them alone you do yeah I turn down
invitations to go to boxing parties I
don't like to be distracted conversation
okay
you know I like to watch interesting
okay and and if I and if I'm too
invested in one of the fighters I don't
want to hear other things oh-hoo-hoo
which inviter are you invested in you
know it's funny because we have this
Canelo fighter yeah fight coming up yeah
so with the triple G and early on I was
a big Canelo fan you know I was much
more I liked him much more than I liked
anybody else mhm now not so much the
drug failure stuff and then also that I
don't know his attitude seems to have
changed somewhat he's arrogant okay the
Russian I think is is more to my liking
okay
now whether or not it plays out in the
ring I think the Russian definitely won
the first fight mm-hmm
you know I didn't blow him out but I
thought he wanted right
so we'll see so when it comes on you
will be I'll watch it by yourself I'm I
saw nobody lots of wine okay is there
any other sporting event that you'd take
in like like that by yourself or USA you
know alone so who is and have that glass
of wine with you here but I could do a
one so who in the UFC or are you have
you taken a liking to there - ah lately
hmm I just saw a Brazilian kid and I
don't know his name okay a fight night a
couple days ago you look very good I
don't know McGregor is always a nerd are
you so weird when McGregor takes on oh
sure babe you know that should be an
interesting fight well how do you suss
out here's the thing I'm gonna go with
McGregor and I'll tell you why okay cuz
I've seen the Russian khabib get rattled
in there with one punch on the chin I've
seen him get hit and do that funny dance
right survive it win the fight but the
guy that hit him on the chin that did
the funny dance was not a good puncher
McGregor can crack if he hits you solid
it's over and you saw the way that he
throws a Dali at a at a bus underneath
Barclays Center dad you saw that yeah I
did see that yeah that was you know it's
out of hand right I mean the whole thing
is out of hand the weigh-ins what is all
that about you know I mean they're not
fighting at the weigh-in that's always
been the case there right well I mean
maybe I mean we've you since you've seen
in in in the history of fights where
you'll get something that seems to be
staged no I don't like throwing a Dali
well that a boss was not stay a little
carried away when but I remember Dempsey
I met Dempsey years ago in New York and
I said you always seemed friendly at the
weigh-ins and he said why not when I
fighting at the weigh-in and plus we're
just we're getting pay we're fighting
for money
right I don't know these guys a
professional yeah and I said well don't
you feel like you have to get amped up
you know like create something sure he
said everybody gets the same thing Ed
O'Neill here on the Rich Eisen show
Modern Family starting season 10 coming
up Wednesday September 26 1905 or
against Edie when you were playing back
in the day and showed up at Steelers
training camp well the best player I
ever played against before I got to the
Steelers mmm-hmm
was Roger Staubach when do you play
against him I played against Roger
Staubach when I was at Youngstown State
University and he was at Pensacola Naval
Station doing his six-year bit wait a
minute this is a great story right yeah
you know you know they do that he
graduated from Annapolis won the Heisman
mmm went down there and played football
for six years and they recruited they
had guys like all-american wide
receivers from SC and you know UCLA
playing on his team they had no line yes
was like a tag football game but he was
the best I ever I played against them
two years so you're playing against the
Pensacola Louisville station Naval
Station yeah
and then out trots Roger Staubach yeah
that's not fair he was a quarterback
that's now these were high scoring close
games really because they didn't have a
running game they didn't have a good
defense they do not well they had a
couple of good players did you rush him
did you get him I take him down say the
truth I I rushed him mm-hmm I got ahold
of him I spun around one time on his leg
and he he just kept wiggling his leg
free and he threw a touchdown pass I hit
him illegally out of bounds once and
they had a guy there their middle
linebacker was a guy named Lynch who was
a was a naval boxing champion yeah who I
think his brothers played one of his
brothers played for Kansas City
okay the Lynch brothers sure and he
wanted to kill me you know because they
loved Roger of course so you almost
started a brawl by hitting Roger
Staubach got it
I was just so tired of chasing him and
you know he just stepped out of bounds
and I thought no I'm
I've been running 25 yards now you know
yeah I just got 15 yards on that O'Neil
oh yeah
okay now I know Roger now you know okay
I don't know about those my next
question a very nice guy you know as you
know he's a very sweet guy so yeah my
mom I'll never forget this moment
I was emceeing the Hall of Fame ceremony
the one year cuz Chris Berman was which
do it does it every year he was
introducing the owner of the bills Ralph
Wilson asked him to be his the the
person who introduces him and this is
back when they had to make a speech now
they just do a video but any rate so
Chris did I was doing this emcee and one
of I don't say who somebody was going on
and on one of the introduces was going
on and on so long the point where I was
able to as emcee get up from my position
and walk offstage and get a drink
because it was hot so I get offstage and
get a drink and Roger Staubach who had
introduced bullet Bob Hayes earlier in
the day was told to go five minutes in
his speech to speak about the
posthumously bullet Bob Hayes yeah and
being the Navy man who you know he went
five minutes on it off and off and he
was now coming up to me complaining to
me is the host about somebody going on
much longer and he did five minutes he
goes rich you know how fair is that
discipline and I thought to myself oh my
god Roger Staubach is bitching me out
yeah and the five-year-old in means like
oh my god Roger Bacon yeah where he
played high school ball unbelievable and
then I remember when he was at Annapolis
and they they had that drive for five
remember those they had those great
jerseys yeah said drive for five on the
back to beat army because they had
beaten army four in a row and you took
your shot at Rogers too I took my shot
at him but I'm telling you he had
different gears you know sure he's Roger
stock tall and lean and and faster than
he looked and so you'd kind of cut him
off at the pass and then he'd just go
the other gear and you miss him and so
who was Ed O'Neill here when you showed
up in church
Steelers training camp who was this mean
joke there was all those guys there yeah
lunk but I never you know he was defense
I was defense so nobody really on
offense but who was I guess they were
all tough guys I mean it was sure no
it's like it was like the Hall of Fame
coming to life well no there was next
year really that they really got the
recruiting and going okay you know that
was all the all the guys that made it
those Super Bowl teams are you saying
you're the dead weight I think I might
have been yeah
how did Chuck Noll cut you what are you
saying he called me in you know I went
into the office and brought my playbook
so I knew you know I was going and he
couldn't have been nicer by the way and
and you know he was complimentary you
know he said you know look you're a
tough kid but you know you're trying to
learn the position I had never played we
didn't have outside linebacker mm-hmm in
the college I played for so it was the
only position I read you know reasonably
could have played and I just didn't have
he didn't have time he said look it's my
first year too so he said I can get you
down with the Eagles the Eagles are
desperate and that would have gone a you
know rental car straight down 80 you
know to the yeah and I and he said it
but it's got to be you got to tell me
right now and I said I'm done
you knew it that you didn't want to go
play for the Eagles no why I don't know
it was it was a spur of the moment this
I had knee problems I was and I was to
be honest I was sick of football and I
said no I'm done
there's something else well it all
worked out ed I don't know modern family
here on the Rich Eisen show let's let's
see I've got a few facts here of you
that's on the Internet Edie Wentz funny
story oh sure one quick one
is it clean did I tell you this it's a
fever gaara's wedding it's clean
okay good yes so if you have a guard his
wedding okay at the reception to Joe
Manganiello to Joe okay a guy comes over
to me and says I worked for a guy who's
your biggest fan
I said well where is he said he's over
there I look over I said that's Franco
Harris he said yeah it's Franco Harris I
said and I just went like this come here
by the way he looks like he can still
play yes oh yeah he comes over and he's
like a little kid I mean he's like mr.
O'Neill I'm your big I said wait a
minute wait man did you know I was a
rookie of the year before you got
he says yeah I know all about that he
did yeah cuz I didn't think he would
have you know yeah he said yeah I do
and I said okay so let me get this
straight I got cut pretty quick
mm-hm you won four Super Bowls and I'm
your biggest such a great guy man I love
Manganiello and fighting Franco Harris
to his wedding
Yanko show an outlaw score why wouldn't
you I bet it was very know a lot of
people of that wedding it was uh I bet
there's a pretty entry it's a four-day
wedding what four days four days I'm
gonna say it was a four five million
dollar affair well it's a good thing
they pay well on Modern Family yes okay
so I've got some celebrity true or false
for Ed O'Neill please hit it Mike del
Tufo you're on the Rich Eisen first one
up you have a black belt in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu true or false that's true no
kidding
so you know that I did not know that
yeah I knew you know Brasilia they were
shown right there you are taking
somebody's buy right there man that's
whirring Gracie okay so you are you you
could take anybody out right now and you
sure I just don't want to lose okay you
know my whole thing is defense okay so
if I came at you I don't know what I
would do I'd probably try to get you by
the gurgel though okay very good
second one Ed O'Neill you trot you
taught social studies in Youngstown Ohio
before you got an act true so you you
you handed Chuck know your playbook and
then went to teach social studies I went
to Florida and I was a bellhop in a
hotel down there okay with my roommate
my roommate was a guy named Sammy and
got hmm whose father was in the Hall of
Fame Boxing Hall of Fame okay Sammy anga
and he was my roommate he pitched short
relief for the Pirates and we were he
was cut I was cut so we were roommates
down in Fort Lauderdale and then he
taught social stand-up to Youngstown and
then I got you know it was a substitute
teacher job right in the inner-city and
I ended up doing a bit with that okay
you know it's a long story
right so then my next fact is your first
on screen TV credit the
a Wikipedia situation is all my children
is that a true story it's probably one
of them cuz I was in New York and I was
getting little soap opera gigs to pay
the rent so who are you as the soap
opera head on I was always like the guy
who kidnapped the whole show the father
I was never you know never the lawyer I
was always the truck driver the
professional killer you know something
like you with a heavy night a guy like
mr. Stubbs miss be me
mr. Stubbs was you know okay you were
the only cast member that appeared in
all 260 episodes of married with
children on every show the iron man of
Merit was the iron man of married will
what's your favorite episode of that oh
my gut and you know what I couldn't say
but I want the ones that pops the mind
is when I played The Godfather I did the
Marlon Brando thing and the potatoes
mm-hmm it was funny I thought it was
funny so you don't have a specific
favorite episode of modern great we did
a great one with Terry Bradshaw when
they dedicated the stadium they were
gonna do it to me and then they found
that he had gone to school there for a
week Terry just did Modern Family yes
yes but the jury thing yeah and well
Peyton Manning was on to Payton Payton
was great I heard I heard cuz you know
we we we run in with Manganiello and yes
don't Street I heard that nobody could
get in in edgewise with Peyton Manning
that you kind of boxed everybody out
when I said that was nice Sherwood might
might my story was with him sure so it
was you know it was all and a band I had
done that you know I told you I did that
timeline right you know I never come
back from the next searchers right that
documentary which is very good it is
very good I mean it so but so you didn't
box anyone out Eric I don't want to tell
any tales out of school but Haden was
great okay
it might it might have rhyme it with
stone feet it might have been even said
to me before we started shooting he was
nervous which surprised me because he's
so great in the commercials he's done
Saturday Night Live done live and I said
I said why why are you nervous right
we're gonna have a ball all right he
said well I'm playing another care
I mean I'm playing I'm not playing me I
said so what he said well I'm not Who am
I gonna be I said who else can you be
you're 18 and last one you upon reading
the script for the first time you knew
Modern Family would be a winner and the
show would last for at least 10 years
that true or false it's true that I said
it's a hit show I didn't know how long
would it last but I knew it was gonna be
a hit show why I don't know why I just
it just read to me like it's a hit show
right and it seems like you guys are
having as much fun as ever it comes
through the toe exactly really well it's
the luckiest job it's it's a great job
everybody gets along it's it's um it's
like the perfect storm you know right
being on being on a hit show for ten
years and enjoying it right well I love
it I love watching it head I always
loved our chats when you come here oh
thanks rich I do too oh oh it's why I
keep coming I appreciate that that means
that means a ton thank you for being
here my pleasure
I don't nail hair on the Rich Eisen show
check out Modern Family when it returns
to ABC on September 26th in its usual
timeslot don't you dare move back with
your phone calls and more here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience